ils se sont couchés tard très tard et
célibataire en vacances entre
célibataires uniquement digèrent leurs
premières sorties en discothèque
on fait plein d'activités en soit on
fait tout ensemble je crois que tu veux
il est là aussi
et puis et puis bah voila quand on n'a
pas l'habitude de sortir justement en
boîte ou faire un karaoké
là on y va entraîner par le groupe une
ancienne ferme charentaise pour
accueillir des solos il ou elle vit
forcément seul cette semaine sept hommes
et deux femmes accueillies par estelle
directrice et maîtresse de maison
alors on est dans la chambre des garçons
cinq jours après cinq jours de l'arrivée
donc la colonie de vacances pour adultes
est célibataire ça privilégie une
ambiance qui fait fusionner ici pour
cela que le centre organise des
activités de groupes walt baptême de
l'air acrobranches on tente de saisir sa
chance avec plus ou moins de réussite
les hormones moi je te fais un massage à
moi je vois plus ça comme un centre de
vacances dans lesquelles il n'y a pas de
coupon donc on est sûr de pas se
retrouver en temps de tenir la chandelle
par exemple célibataire il va se sentir
mal à l'aise dans un hôtel standard qui
n'est pas fait pour lui parce qu'il
voyait tout seul alors que nous à ce
qu'on propose justement c'est une
structure complètement réservé aux
célibataires qui est fait pour eux des
solos ensemble sur la plage
probablement un avantage pour être
abordée par deux jeunes femmes
on essaie de provoquer la chance n'est
ce pas y aller vraiment dans l'optique
que rencontrer au moyen de ce type de
séjour entre 700 et 900 euros ou des
âmes seules parfois en quelques dames
seules